les manifestants bien visible et bien
bruit en france qui a tourné au ralenti
dans les grandes villes comme les plus
petites
partout le même ras-le-bol des
carburants trop cher quand vous achetez
votre essence en fait vous payer
quasiment que des taxes la douleur des
gilets jaunes c'est celle de la
retraitée fatigué qui a l'impression que
la vie lui coûte toujours davantage je
peux pas vivre correctement
si je veux vivre un petit peu
normalement si je veux faire une petite
gâterie à la fin du mois effet pas
possible
la colère des gilets jaunes c'est celle
du français de la petite ville qui se
sent méprisée et ignorée par les
dirigeants c'est ce dédain qui m'a fait
venir si vous voulez cette espèce de
dédain excusez moi le terme de produire
de la classe citadins des gilets jaunes
c'est de sentir que certains français
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux que
plusieurs autres
en france c'est liberté égalité égalité
fraternité alou l'égalité à nous la
fraternité la frustration d'un gilet
jaune elle s'accumule depuis des années
la hausse des prix du carburant a fait
déborder le réservoir
donc il est temps d'arrêter de grenier
dans son canapé derrière sa télé
il est temps d'agir il est temps de se
lever
une frustration soudainement devenu bien
visibles et qui n'a pas été sans
conséquence ici un policier est renversé
par un automobiliste au moins une
manifestante a été tué dans des
circonstances similaires
les autorités rapportent une centaine de
blessés
à paris les gilets jaunes ont tenté de
livrer leur message sous les fenêtres du
palais présidentiel ils ont remonté les
champs elysées et bloqué les voies
autour de l'arc de triomphe passé il
fallait être patient et vêtir de sa
devenue symbole du mouvement ça ennuie
ce qu'on fait sans vie des gens c'est
vrai et ça c'est ennuyeux parce que
c'est parce qu'on veut mais on peuvent
rien faire on peut rien construire sont
détruits en veut c'est donc une première
journée de gestes d'éclat réussi pour ce
jeune mouvement des gilet jaune
la question est maintenant de savoir
jusqu'où les héros ici est né du mot
varrault radio-canada paris